can't believe it's the last couple days
and at the same time it's such a full
life that you're kind of like ready for
a little break but it I always love
being here it's always inspiring she's
back
Gwen Stefani is officially returning as
a coach on season 19 of The Voice and a
source tells ET she's over the moon
about it I guess you never know what's
gonna happen next
Gwen and her boyfriend fellow voice
coach Blake Shelton have been
quarantined together at his ranch in
Oklahoma
amid the corona virus pandemic but now
our source says she's ready to get back
to work
quote as much as Gwen loves her family
life at home she needs that outlet she
is a hard worker and so motivated
she says it's in her blood the singer
will be joined on the show by Blake and
returning coaches John Legend and Kelly
Clarkson anytime I can be around Blake
is it's you know a blessing of course
the 50 year old Entertainer left the
show ahead of the 18th season to do her
Las Vegas residency show and Nick Jonas
took her spot I think it was a bizarre
moment when I went up and sat in my
chair and I look to my left and right
and you know that's a cool cool feeling
to be a part of that company and Annie
Blake and John Legend Kelly Clarkson and
I was just honored to be there but now
according to our source
Gwen's ready and raring to go getting a
team of hair makeup and wardrobe people
together to prep for her big return and
get this the source added that Gwen
refers to her role on the hit
competition show as one of her favorite
jobs ever it's just such a great amazing
place to be I love it quote she
considers the cast and crew like her
second family and missed them so much
while they weren't filming I love being
here as for her relationship status with
her longtime beau et source says she's
in no hurry to rush down the aisle
adding that she's put any wedding plans
on the back burner Gwen and Blake trust
and love each other and have truly built
a wonderful family together so right now
she feels like she doesn't need to rock
the boat
Blake saved my life everybody knows that
like we're just half
the time of our lives and we never
expected that at this late in our lives
so we're just trying to save forever
every moment together back in 2019 Blake
told et how they would reveal a
potential engagement if that were to
happen the amount of time we've been
together in our relationship it just
gets stronger every day the bond and I
promise you we won't break the news in
any of the grocery store trash magazines
when it happens you'll hear about it and
naturally he couldn't help but gush
about his leading lady she's never not
been supportive or a cheerleader it's
just just the most encouraging person
I've ever had in my life on any level
it's unbelievable how supportive she is
[Music]